EMERGENCY WORKERS.
>> Tucker: I THINK EVERYONE
AGREES.
THANK YOU.
SO YOU SAW WHAT’S HAPPENING IN
NEW YORK, THE QUESTION IS WHY IS
THE OUTBREAK SO ESPECIALLY
DEVASTATING THEY ARE?
NEW YORK CITY IS THE DENSEST
METRO AREA IN THE COUNTRY,
THAT’S THE MOST OBVIOUS ANSWER
AND THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
THE CITY HAS AN AWFUL LOT OF
PEOPLE TRAVELING TO AND FROM
OTHER INFECTED COUNTRIES AND
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT TOO BUT IT’S
NOT THE WHOLE STORY.
THIS DEADLY VIRUS EMERGE FROM
EASTERN CHINA AND BEGAN TO
SPREAD ACROSS THE GLOBE CLEARLY
HEADED HERE, THEY NOT ONLY
FAILED TO SHIELD THEIR CITIZENS
FROM IT, THEY TOOK AFFIRMATIVE
AND AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO INCREASE
THE RISK THEIR POPULATION.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE THEY WERE WORRIED FAR
MORE ABOUT BEING CALLED RACIST
THAN PROTECTING HUMAN LIVES.
THAT IS NOT ACUTE LACK OF
OVERSTATEMENT OR HYPERBOLE.
WATCH HIM URGE NEW YORKERS TO
SPEND AS MUCH TIME AS POSSIBLE
IN CROWDED PUBLIC PLACES.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS VIDEO IS FROM
FEBRUARY 2ND OF THIS YEAR LONG
AFTER THE THREAT FROM THE
CHINESE CORONAVIRUS WAS OBVIOUS
TO ANYONE WHO IS PAYING
ATTENTION.
>> THE RISK TO NEW YORKERS FOR
CORONAVIRUS IS LOW, AND OUR
PREPAREDNESS AS A CITY IS VERY
HIGH.
THERE IS NO REASON NOT TO TAKE
THE SUBWAY, NOT TO TAKE THE BUS,
NOT TO GO OUT TO YOUR FAVORITE
RESTAURANT, AND CERTAINLY NOT TO
MISS THE PARADE NEXT SUNDAY.
>> Tucker: TAKE THE SUBWAY, GO
TO DINNER, PEOPLE CHEER.
THEY FEEL GOOD ABOUT THEMSELVES.
FUTURE GENERATIONS ARE GOING TO
WATCH THAT VIDEO WITH THEIR JAWS
OPEN IN DISBELIEF.
HOW COULD SOMEONE CHARGE THE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH SO
RECKLESSLY ENDANGERING?
WATCH THIS PERFORMANCE FROM
STATE SENATOR JOHN BLUE.
HE SUGGESTED THAT PEOPLE MIGHT
BE CONCERNED IN ANY WAY ABOUT
CONTRACTING A DEADLY DEASE
MUST BE, AND YOU GUESSED IT,
BIGOTS.
>> THERE IS NO NEED TO PANIC AND
TO AVOID ACTIVITIES THAT WE
ALWAYS DO AS NEW YORKERS.
WE ARE HARDY PEOPLE.
AS AND ASIAN-AMERICAN, I’VE BEEN
DISTURBED IF NOT OUTRIGHT
APPALLED BY SOME OF THE COMMENTS
OR GESTURES THAT I HAVE SEEN.
DISEASES ORIGINATE FROM ANYWHERE
OR FROM PARTICULAR PLACES IN THE
WORLD.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS, AS
A MEMBER OF A PROTECTED INTEREST
GROUP, I AM ORDERING YOU TO
IGNORE THIS THREAT TO YOUR
FAMILY ON MORAL GROUNDS.
GO TO THE PARADE OR ELSE.
THAT’S WHAT HE’S SAYING.
LET’S HOPE THAT IN THE WAKE OF
THIS DISASTER AFTER JOHN LOU HAS
LOST HIS JOB AND WE CAN ALL
THINK CLEARLY AGAIN, PEOPLE WILL
STOP TALKING THIS WAY IN PUBLIC
FOR GOOD.
ALWAYS THE MOST BRUTAL FORM OF
SOCIAL CONTROL MASQUERADING A
SENSITIVITY AND CARING.
NOW WE KNOW IT WAS INFECTING THE
PUBLIC WITH DISEASE BUT AT THE
TIME, SENTIMENTS LIKE THIS WERE
UNIVERSAL AMONG BIG-CITY PUBLIC
OFFICIALS.
STATE SENATOR BRIAN KAVANAUGH
FOR EXAMS EXAMPLE A EUPHEMISM AS
OFTEN IS FOR ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
KAVANAUGH ENCOURAGED PEOPLE TO
HEAD TO CHINATOWN FOR A FESTIVAL
FESTIVAL.
>> IT’S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS HOLIDAY AND
THIS FESTIVAL IS OF TREMENDOUS
SIGNIFICANCE FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE AND IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ENSURE
THAT WE DON’T HAVE
MISINFORMATION AND MANY IN THE
MEDIA HAVE BEEN COVERING THIS
ISSUE AS IF IT IS A TERRIBLE
PLAGUE THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO AVOID
AVOID.
>> Tucker: IF YOU DON’T GO TO
A CROWDED PUBLIC PLACE
IMMEDIATELY, HUMOR RACIST.
LOOK AT THOSE PEOPLE TELLING YOU
THAT, DEMANDING THAT YOU DO
THAT.
BAD DURING YOU, EXERTING MORAL
BLACKMAIL ON YOU TO EXPOSE
YOURSELF.
BY EARLY MARCH, CORONAVIRUS WAS
CLEARLY BECOMING A MAJOR PROBLEM
BUT ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
NEW YORK THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS
THEIR CONSTITUENTS RACIST
WORRIES ABOUT STAYING ALIVE.
ON MARCH 2ND, THIS MARCH 2ND,
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO TWEETED
THIS, "SINCE I’M ENCOURAGING
NEW YORKERS TO GO ON WITH THEIR
LIVES PLUS GET ON THE TOWN
DESPITE CORONAVIRUS, I THOUGHT
IT WOULD OFFER SOME SUGGESTIONS.
HERE’S THE FIRST.
THROUGH THURSDAY, GO SEE THE
TRAITOR.
THE WIRE WAS A TRUE STORY PLUS
SET IN ITALY, IT WOULD BE THIS
FILM.
GO TO A MOVIE THEATER
IMMEDIATELY, YOU MUST.
A WEEK LATER, HE WAS STILL
ENCOURAGING NEW YORKERS TO LIVE
IT UP AND MINGLE IN LARGE GROUPS
GROUPS.
ON MARCH 11TH WHICH WAS BARELY
TWO WEEKS AGO, HE WAS STILL
INSISTING THAT "IF YOU’RE NOT
SICK, YOU SHOULD BE GOING ABOUT
YOUR LIFE.
"THAT VERY SAME DAY, THE NBA
ANNOUNCED IT WAS SUSPENDING ITS
WHOLE SEASON.
ITALY WAS ALREADY SEVERED SEVERA
INTO A NATIONAL LOCKDOWN BUT THE
MAYOR OF ONE OF THE MOST CROWDED
CITIES WAS TELLING PEOPLE TO
CARRY ON AND THAT THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS WAS JUST A RACIST
MYTH.
SOON AFTER THAT, PEOPLE
INEVITABLY STARTED TO GET SICK
AND IN SOME CASES THEY DIED.
SHRIEKING THAT DONALD TRUMP HAD
ABANDONED THE CITY.
WAS THEIR FAULT, ALL THEIR FAULT
FAULT.
THAT LINE ALMOST ALWAYS WORKS
WHICH IS WHY HE DID IT, THE
MEDIA PLAY ALONG AND MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT THING AND NO ONE
REMEMBERS WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
WILL THAT HAPPEN THIS TIME?
MAYBE NOT.
THIS TIME MIGHT BE DIFFERENT.
THIS PANDEMIC IS TOO HORRIBLE,
TOO MANY PEOPLE GETTING HURT.
WELL IT DID WAS HELP
MEDIOCRITIES LIKE
BILL de BLASIO GET ELECTED TO
OFFICE BUT IT WAS DISGUSTING AND